hey everyone welcome back to how to
Hollywood I'm your host Kristen Gill and
today I have celebrity makeup artist
extraordinaire Miss Joe Baker with me hi
so tell me what you're going to be doing
today I am going to be showing you how
to do a monochromatic Rose tone satin
eye with a matching lip and cheek but
subtle she recently did this look on
lily Reinhardt from Riverdale so if you
guys want to learn how to recreate it
just keep watching
okay so Joe has prepped my skin tell me
what you've done so far some good
skincare sis the eye contour mask just
to hydrate and plump it up around the
eye area a good moisturizer and some
armani luminous silk a little bit of
NARS concealer here and there and a
little bit of clay to PO around the nose
area just to make everything even and
smooth and creamy we're gonna show
everybody at home how to do a
monochromatic rosy tone eye and lip
paired together so using quite a nice
big soft fluffy blender I'm gonna go
straight into this delicious pinky tone
right here and I start at the center and
I'm just gonna build up the rosy pinky
tone color on the eye base the reason
why I like using this kind of soft
fluffy blender brush is that you can
really build and smoke it out as you go
it ends up just looking softer a little
tickly taps all over the lid starting
off in the middle and then pulling it up
right there how did you come up with
this look for Lily her dress inspired me
so she had like a cool marooning toned
dress on and I wanted to do something
that you know brought out the dress
color made it all kind of fun and young
and interesting I didn't want to go for
typical brown or Gray's I wanted to give
her something that would kind of really
pull out her eye color yeah she has
amazing blue blue tone eyes hmm anything
this kind of vibrant and this kind of
color palette really helps green and
blue eyes shoot forward and I'm gonna do
the same color soft me underneath the
eye but is it wise to be writing about
gangs and drugs while you're going to
school here really plays such a
button-down character on Riverdale
uh-huh
is she more playful when it comes to
makeup was she like do whatever you want
he was really carefree and she allowed
me to create a look without any
resistance yes my favorite that's great
yeah so it's always nice when someone's
got a adventurous spirit and wants to
really just go for it
so there's your base with the brightest
color in the palette and now we're gonna
go back and kind of build up the the
crease and create dimension because with
these colors it's really important that
you have like a crease color sometimes
it can if I just did mascara now it
would look it would look a little flat
yeah so we want to create a nice crease
use the same color palette add in a
little bit of deeper tone towards the
lash line this color right here this
super bright red when did you meet Lilly
I met her that day really yeah and I'd
only just started watching Riverdale
mm-hmm a weekend a week before I got
booked with her it's so good good we
have another host man Aguilera she's our
host of Sweetwater secrets she has a
show based off Riverdale and she had
Lily on a couple times when you have to
film those more intimate scenes what is
it like for you as an actor to do that I
mean it's the CW you're not you're not
getting too crazy it's just like I mean
hanging and hugging it so are you more
of a Betty or Veronica night Veronica me
too I do a Betty but she's pretty ba you
know yeah she's just enough mean just
enough cool water of a lone you know
when she first came on the scene an
introductory outfit looks like oh yeah
hello who are you
so I'm now gonna go to Anastasia and
their Modern Renaissance so I'm gonna
get antique bronze and red oak laughs I
like that
bricky burnt
maroon color so we're just gonna smush
that into the lashline pulling up at the
edges and this will just help the lashes
look nice and voluminous at the root and
it's always good to take a neutral tone
it's just I've got a soft rosy taupe and
I'm just gonna use that to like soften
around the edges these are the colours
we've got going on on the face right now
and we're gonna add in an eggplant on
the inside of the eye and you can see
how much more dramatic this like I look
goes from like soft hazy rosy she nice
it's gonna get a little bit more
nighttime just gonna smush that along so
I like that the eyeliner ends up
blending with the eyeshadow underneath
so we're going inside the waterline top
and bottom add that intensity and we're
just gonna blend this on them a little
bit on the top of the lash line right
hand so now we're gonna go back in the
eye shadows all done but now we're gonna
go back in and conceal this is what will
help brighten it up make it look
controlled
I'm loving this Gucci blush right now
and this one is called spicy petal I'm
just patting it other than dusting it
because I don't want to lift any
foundation I also think it can look
really natural when we buff and Pat it
in like this instead of a swipe and then
on the lips keeping with our
monochromatic tones
add in Laura Mercier and I know that
because I've got all the names written
on the back since psycho if Gloria
Mercier is sensual
no lipliner just gonna pull in a little
bit of that palette that we've got going
on the eyes I'm gonna bring it out in
the lipstick so you've got the lip cheek
and eyes all in the same monochromatic
palette but the eyes are the standout
feature and the rest of the
complimentary tons
thank you so much Joe for being here
you're welcome is pleasure to be here so
I had to change my top because Joe was
like these stripes are not working with
that eye we need dark colors so thank
you Denny this is your sweater I just
wanted a black frame I needed neutrals I
really wanted the pink eyes to pop and I
think it just looks more dramatic and
makes more sense with dog clothing so
make sure you guys like and subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
and let me know in the comments down
below what you guys want to see next and
I will see you in the next one bye guys
[Music]